From the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.
Good morning. It is June 29, 2016. This is David Klein of the History Department at Virginia Tech,
and also working with the Southern oral history program at UNC in Chapel Hill.
This morning we are recording for the Civil Rights History Project and we are in San Diego, California.
This project is sponsored by the Library of Congress and also the Smithsonian's National Museum of African American History and Culture.
Behind the camera today we have John Bishop of Media Generation and UCLA.
We are also joined behind the camera by Guha Shankar of the Library of Congress and Jessica Jawat of Pillars of the Community,
which is a local organization we will hear a little bit more about here in San Diego.
So we are incredibly honored to be able to spend some time this morning with the Bird Alexander.
This is the one time I will coach you at all in our entire conversation,
but if you could introduce yourself with a full sentence, I am, or my name is,
and your name and where and when you are born.
Oh, I'm a Bird Alexander and I was born in December 1946 in Berkeley, California.
So, Bird, I would love to start with telling us a little bit about your family background
and how that may have influenced you as you grew up.
My family background definitely influenced me and my brother and sister very, very much.
Not my great grandfather, my grandfather was a slave.
And that seems hard to imagine if you try to do the math, but he was born in 1842 and he died in 1942.
And the article that was written about him in an Omaha newspaper said,
wrote about his having been a slave and my father had known he had been a slave,
and also wrote about him having participated in the Pony Express.
My father grew up on the between the Omaha Indian Reservation and Su City, Iowa.
So, most of his life he identified as not a member of the tribe,
because he knew he wasn't a member of the tribe, but all of his friends were kids from the reservation
or the kids in Su City, Iowa, who were like the children of packing house workers.
Because his mother would go there to work in the packing houses at that time.
How did he come to be associated with the reservation?
Because of his father. His father actually spoke, my grandfather spoke,
Winnebago, Omaha, and Su.
And according to my dad, Su and Omaha are closely related languages and Winnebago is more different.
And according to family lore, he got this job on the Pony Express,
which would not have lasted very long, because the Pony Express was only in existence for about a year and a half.
But because he could speak the Indian languages and could go through some areas where other people couldn't go.
And he did it on the condition that he would tell the white people nothing about what the Indians were doing.
So, they ended up living there.
But it was mostly my grandmother who was home.
My grandfather did lots of different things.
He was an itinerant musician, actually.
And he played the Jews harp, and he traveled with the guy named Giles, who played the 12th string guitar.
He also was a bootlegger for a period of time.
He also wrestled cattle and sold cattle.
So, he was not home very often, but he did manage to have 10 children.
And my grandmother was little Scott Irish lady who ended up living mostly on the reservation.
Amazing family background.
And so, and then you are your own father in his siblings.
So, my father was born in the 18th century.
My father was born in 1914.
So, if you do the math, his father was pretty old when he was born.
My father had nine siblings, five girls and five boys.
And three of the girls died of different things.
One of the flu, the flu pandemic, another of tuberculosis, and the third one in a fire.
When they were home, because they were often home alone.
When she was working in the packing houses in Susie, Iowa, and I think she was ironing or something.
And there was a fire, and so she died in that.
And did he stay your father in that area?
Well, that's an interesting question, because no, in the end he came to California.
But growing up, he, he, at one point we did an oral history with my dad.
And at one point he said, home, what was home?
We were always staying with different people.
So, if you think about it, his mother also died fairly early, because she had tuberculosis.
She died when he was 15.
But growing up, he was sometimes in Susie, Iowa, with his mother.
He was sometimes on the reservation with his mother.
At other times, he was with his brother, Earl Alexander.
And at another time, he was in Flint, Michigan, with another brother, Mark Alexander,
who worked in the automobile plants.
And was very religious, and my father sort of ran away from there,
but he worked as a bell hop in Flint, Michigan.
So, between the years of 10 and 15, he must have lived in 10 or 15 different places.
And done, just as many jobs.
There's one in particular that I would like you to tell you about when he was about 12.
He decided to work, to ride the rails, and get work in the harvest in Minnesota.
And when we had the reunion for our family on the reservation,
we could see that the rail lines go right through the reservation.
It would have been easy for him to hop on.
So, he did, a 12-year-old, 12-13-years-old.
He goes to Minnesota, riding the rails.
He gets off some place, and he asks around, does anybody need any help doing the harvest?
So, he finds this farmer, and the guy says, yeah, I need some help.
And this is where I live, and come out at 6 o'clock or something like that, and I'll get you set up.
And he gave my dad some money to buy some food, but he didn't give him any money to get out to the farm.
The farm was about five miles out, or he didn't offer him a ride, I should say.
And my dad gets out there, and the farmer is doing chores, so my dad helps him do the chores with the different animals,
the chickens, and milk, and all the cows, and everything.
Then he goes into the bunk house, and the farmer's wife brings him food.
He always talks about food, because that was really important, because he said he was hungry 99% of the time, so he says,
she brought me sandwiches, and some milk, and I thought, oh, this is cool.
And the farmer offered to pay me 50 cents a day, and that's terrific.
So, he notices that in the bunk house there's a bunch of all-grown men, and they're all white, of course.
So, anyway, one of them comes up to him, and they say, so, what are you doing here?
Koon, or some kind of, you know, derogatory term, or really my dad would say he didn't know what that meant at that stage.
And he says, well, I'm here to work the harvest.
The guy says, really, you're here to work the harvest? He says, yeah.
He says, what's he paying you? 50 cents a day, and the guy says, 50 cents a day, and you're doing chores on top of it?
And he says, yeah, because he's so proud of himself.
And the guy says to him, they're Scandinavian, by the way.
My father say, they're Swedes, nor Weedgeans, and so forth.
And the guy says, you can't work for 50 cents a day.
You're a worker just like we are.
You have to get a dollar a day, just like we do.
Then my dad says, oh, oh, this is terrific, you know, but he's kind of nervous because the guy was calling him a shine and a koon.
And all of these things.
So next morning at breakfast, my dad explains the breakfast sausage, biscuits, gravy, pancakes, bacon, eggs.
And he says in the middle of all of this feast, this guy stands up and tells the farmer, we understand you're hiring this boy for 50 cents a day.
And the farmer says, that's right.
And he says, no, you can't do that.
Either you fire him or you give him a dollar a day.
And then the guy says, well, I don't know what to do.
He says, no, actually, you give him a dollar a day or we strike.
And my dad's going, strike, he's going to strike.
I barely finished my breakfast because he knew what a strike was.
He had lived in Su City, Iowa with his mother in the late teens and in the early 20s.
And there were strikes at the packing house.
And he would describe all of the people who were on strike.
And it was amazing because he listed Mexicans, Syrians, and Poles and Russians, as well as a few black folks and a few Indians.
And at that time, there was a real campaign of terror against the strikers.
So for example, my dad would never sit at night in front of a window that was not covered.
Ku Klux Klan would march down the street.
And he felt they targeted his mom, but then he's because she had these black kids.
But then he said, no, they targeted everybody.
And they would throw rocks in the windows and terrorized folks.
So back to the breakfast.
He says, strike, we can't go strike.
I have barely finished my breakfast.
And the guy says, nope, we're going to do this.
So the owner says, well, okay.
But he's got to carry his weight.
So my dad starts working with him.
And he's running as fast as he can.
And it was what they called shocking grain.
So the grain would be cut.
And then they would pick it up and tie it up and pile it in piles.
So he was running.
So the guy says to him, what's you doing running like that?
You're not supposed to be setting the pace.
You see him?
You go as fast as he goes and you don't go any faster.
He says, okay, I'm just trying to prove.
Excuse me.
I'm just trying to prove that I can keep up my,
keep up with everybody else.
So the long story short, he works there for about a month.
He makes about $30.
And he's so happy.
He's getting ready to go home.
And the guy says, okay.
So now you understand where the industrial workers of the world
and you need to join.
And so you can get a membership for $0.10 a month.
And here's your card.
So my dad gave the guy $30.
And he had a little red card for being a member of the I.W.W.
And at that time, I guess he might have been the youngest one.
And also he was a black kid up in the Midwest.
And it was pretty, it was a pretty special designation.
What an amazing, amazing story.
So that's just one story.
We've just started.
I can't wait for the rest of this.
Fantastic.
Yes, thank you.
I think that story is very important because he had,
although his mother was white, he was always around the Native Americans
and the African Americans who were living in Su City.
And he said he didn't know very many white people.
And yet he had this experience where these grown white guys stood up for his rights.
He was a little scared because they were known for, like, they would burn somebody's field down.
They were anarchists, I guess, in part.
And he was frightened by the whole thing.
And he was also confused.
And he spoke up when he spoke up to the guy.
He says, you guys are calling me shine and cool and all those.
That makes me feel kind of funny.
I would prefer you just call me by my name.
And that was kind of interesting.
And most of them did, but they would forget and call him those names anyway.
But I think that was a very formative moment for him, as well as having experienced as a child,
his mother's work in the packing house and the strikes there,
which were very multiracial, multiethnic.
Now did he tell you these stories when you were growing up?
Did you know these stories of the unions?
I only knew some of these stories.
I didn't really get any of the details until we did oral history on him in 1975.
I knew about the Indians because they showed up in Los Angeles once.
The whole family didn't tell anybody and they just arrived.
And we took care of them, half of them, half my cousins had TB.
And they were put in sanitariums.
But we had other cousins who would stay at different brothers' houses in LA.
So I knew about that.
And we would do stuff like the squad dance and things like that.
And we would eat fried bread when they came.
Yeah.
So you had some awareness of this.
Oh yeah, I had awareness of it.
Yeah, I did.
So how about, so you said your father eventually ended up in California,
but can you tell us a bit about your mother?
Okay.
Can I tell you a little more about my grandmother?
Absolutely.
So my father only went to about the fifth grade.
And my grandmother was a real fighter.
And this is another part of making my dad who he was.
For example, he loved school.
He even talked about how he liked his teachers.
This is when he would have been in Su City.
And they had a substitute one day.
And the substitute was mean.
And she was hitting the kids on their fingers with a ruler.
So he got hit once.
And then I don't know what he did.
He doesn't even remember what he did.
And he said to himself,
she's not going to hit me no more.
And he snatched the ruler out of her hand,
broke it in half, and threw it out the window.
Well, this substitute teacher kind of had a fit after that happened very upset
and was taking him out of school.
He went home and told his mother what happened.
His mother came back and you know they had ink wells at that time.
And she just picked up the ink well, she told off this woman
for treating the children badly and she threw the ink at this teacher.
And then they marched away.
Another time they were trying to get enrolled in school and they didn't have shoes.
And they said, you can't have shoes.
So the mother said, well, let's just go.
They left.
And he needed to find work anywhere and not anyway.
And that's when his education stopped.
So imagine, sushi to the Iowa and you don't have shoes.
So my mother's family,
that's another story.
My grandmother comes from Vilna,
which is Lithuania.
We grew up understanding that it was sometimes Russian,
it was sometimes Poland.
And they were Jewish.
And they immigrated, well, the family was very revolutionary.
They were anti-zar.
And they,
that the family back there was Orthodox Jew,
the family that she grew up in.
But she and almost all of her siblings eventually came to the United States
after 1905 revolution.
And my grandfather was Russian and I don't know where he was from.
But he Russian Jew.
But he was a very angry, bitter, mean man.
He had a shoe repair store in St. Louis.
And when my mother later met my father in California,
he disowned her, my mother, because my father was black.
Well, we said, need grow at that time.
And so my grandmother decided to leave him because she was not going to disown her daughter.
Yeah.
And this whole, all of her siblings,
they did not practice Judaism as a religion really,
but they spoke Yiddish.
That was their main language.
They were culturally Jewish.
And they were all very, very progressive and involved in the movement in some way or another.
My grandmother worked in the garment industry.
My grandmother was very upset with the Jewish religion,
because for example, the boys could go to school and she couldn't.
So my grandmother was essentially illiterate.
She could read a little bit of Yiddish
and she could add, and very little bit of English, her whole life.
But they were always very, very progressive.
And my parents met because at some young communist league party in Los Angeles.
I have a lot of stories about how my father decided to become a communist.
I don't know if you have time for them.
How about one or two?
One or two.
So my father, when he was maybe 12, did a short job in the packing house,
which was, and just involved opening the door so somebody else carrying a big hunk of meat could get through.
And he worked as a shoe shine boy at different places for a lot of his life at that age.
And as a shoe shine boy, somebody came by, some young woman, he said,
came by God of shoe shine, and then left him a copy of the Communist Manifesto.
So he's trying to read the Communist Manifesto, because he's kind of impressed.
Nobody ever gave him a book before or anything, but he didn't have the skills to do it.
So he asked his boss, and his boss says, that's terrible.
That's terrible stuff.
He says, oh, okay, and he throws it away.
And then when his boss is not there, he picks it up again.
And he had a very good relationship with the banker in town,
and even figured out how to borrow $50 from the banker for his brother to buy a truck.
He had this nice relationship, so he figured the banker could help him.
So he shows the banker, his copy of the Communist Manifesto, and the banker says,
that's just terrible, revolutionary crap, terrible, terrible.
So my father throws it away again.
But then he starts thinking, well, this is kind of an interesting book.
And he keeps trying, but he really can't read it.
And at some point, this young woman comes back, and she says, how are you doing with the book?
And he says, actually, I can't read it.
I can't read well enough.
I'd be happy to talk to you about it, but I can't read.
And then he was invited to a party, and was rather amazed, you know,
that the party was all white people.
And he mentioned Jews and Russians and Scandinavians and things like that at the party.
But everybody was nice to him and inclusive, and they started,
when they heard his stories, they could not believe his background,
and that they were very friendly.
And that's how he started to get involved.
And then later on, working in the packing house,
because he then got real job in the packing house when he was 16 or 17.
And I guess he was talking to these folks at the time,
and talking to the workers in the packing houses,
and the packing houses actually haven't changed that much.
He said, we would be in a foot of manure, and there would be blood everywhere,
and your hands would be very slippery, and it was extremely dangerous,
and there were always people at the doors ready to take your place,
and they were always training new people.
And they worked 10 to 13 hour days,
and they had 20 minutes for a lunch break.
And he talked about how they would drink blood just to keep themselves going.
Some positions were not on a conveyor belt, but other positions were.
And they would start at 250, not goats, sheep going by,
in the morning, and then they would gradually increase it,
and sometimes it got up to 350.
And so he talked to the guys and said, well, what are we going to do about this?
Because it's so dangerous when it gets up, because people would cut themselves,
very serious, no breaks.
And he says, what are we going to do?
And somebody said, well, if they go over at 350, let's strike.
My dad said, okay, maybe he was the guy who said, let's strike.
Anyway, of course, they went over 350.
My dad said, hold the line, and they all walked out.
So it was a wildcat strike.
He got fired and blacklisted, and everybody else went back to work.
But what's really interesting about that story is, if you read the book, fast food nation,
very little has changed.
In fact, I mean, these packing houses are larger,
but the jobs are very close to being as dangerous.
And they talk about the speed of the line, exactly the same stuff,
mostly immigrant workers.
And this was in Los Angeles, right?
The packing house was in Sus City, and in Omaha.
And then the depression was very, very difficult.
And after he got blacklisted, though, that's when he came to California.
So perhaps talking about California and how your parents met and then your own childhood.
Okay, so my parents met in the Young Communist League movement as well.
And how old were they?
They were probably in their young 20s, and it was interracial couples.
It was illegal at that time.
So they had a common law marriage.
My mother was kind of the person who kept my dad going, but she wasn't the person with the big stories
who gave the speeches and things like that.
He worked in California all up and down the Central Valley with cotton-conpress workers organizing for the CIO.
And he also worked with the ILWU organizing African-American workers.
And I think especially interesting for this project was that in the late 40s and early 50s,
he was the director of the Civil Rights Congress in Oakland, California.
And they worked on police brutality, housing rights.
They were attacked by the Oakland Tribune, Nolan newspapers.
And one thing I talked about, lynching is genocide.
This is a very important and little known organization.
Yes.
And what I think what's really important is, yes, he did identify as a communist.
But what the communists did was organize for people's rights, for decent wages, for a place to live,
against police brutality, really basic people's rights.
They weren't armed and going out to shoot people to have a revolution.
It was their idea was, let's help the people where we are now.
And that's part of the organizing effort for the Congress of Industrial Organizations to,
the CIO, was to be much more inclusive in terms of who was able to, who was unionized in an official way.
Yeah.
And your parents had met as young communists as your mother, retained those politics as well.
She did. They didn't retain those politics.
I mean, they both quit probably in the very early 60s,
because lots of different issues that were going on.
She did a lot of support stuff like, I remember as a child going door to door selling the people's world.
And going to a few demonstrations like about the Brosenbergs, it seems to, I would have been pretty small.
And my dad, even after he stopped working as an organizer for unions and became a shoe repairman,
he would go hang out at the laborers' local in Los Angeles,
which was kind of a sold out local and then organized the workers to sort of struggle within the union for to change.
And he organized an organization called the Laborers' Fraternal Order.
And they had a logo, you know, they would have, they had these buttons,
and they had a logo with a brown arm, a white arm, and a black arm.
In fact, I have a brochure that shows you that.
Again, that was called the Laborers' Fraternal Organization.
Laborers' Fraternal Order, I think.
And it was a support group they had out.
They had a baseball team, you know, it was community, a little bit like pillars of the community.
So can you tell us a little bit about your own, obviously just a very typical childhood.
Yeah.
Tell us a little bit about your childhood.
Well, my childhood was kind of interesting because I was the youngest.
And so my brother and sister remember suffering more than I did.
Some of my earliest memories when my father went underground,
he kind of, he disappeared during the McCarthy era.
And of course, I didn't really know what that was about.
But we lived with my uncle Mark in Paris, California, P-E-R-R-I-S,
which one was one of the few places where black people could buy land in the 30s and the 40s.
Where about says that?
It's off 15.
Where's it off the 163?
Not too far from Riverside.
Okay.
South West of Riverside.
So it's a dry, rocky area.
Very hard.
You wouldn't make a living off the farm.
And so we were country kids, and we looked like it in a couple of photographs that we have.
My brother at the age of 12 dug a well.
This will give you an idea.
He dug the well.
He still had the chair before he died to show us what he had done.
And everybody in that family worked very hard.
Like I was like the assistant.
So birdie, go get this, birdie, go get that.
You know, I was that person because he needed somebody.
My sister worked very hard.
And they were very frugal.
The family was very frugal.
I didn't feel like I suffered at all.
I felt, I thought everything was fine.
But once a week we would go to the grocery store with my uncle's truck
and take everything that they were throwing away.
And we would bring that food back to our little farm.
It was a five acre farm.
To our little farm and sort through it and decide what we could keep to eat and what we'd go to the pigs.
And we kind of did that, you know.
My uncle also worked as a custodian on Camp Pendleton, and he got fired.
And he got fired because he was my father's brother.
Period.
This particular uncle was not political.
And they were very religious.
One of these sort of, it was the church of God in Christ.
What do they call it?
They would sing, they would find the holy ghost.
They would kind of light a half fits and stuff and speak in tongues and everything.
Patek Ostle.
I don't know.
I don't know technically.
There's a couple of words for them.
Anyhow, they had this rusty, dusty little church with benches,
that do splinters and everything.
And according to my brother and sister, we went like three times a week.
Not just on Sunday, but during the week.
I don't remember so much about it, except I did have nightmares for about three years of a devil chasing me.
What else did I want to tell you about this period?
Oh, yes.
We were followed.
My brother, my sister and my uncle,
would be often followed when we were driving around because the FBI would be in some white,
not white, black, forward or Chevrolet.
And they would follow my uncle like we were doing anything.
And so my uncle decided one day, he wasn't political, but still he wanted to mess with these guys.
So he went and parked in a cold sat, it's country, but it was like a dead end under a tree.
And then it just stayed there.
So they had to be in the sun, and this would be 100 degrees.
In Paris, California, then sometimes you go out and say,
what do you guys follow us around for?
So I remember that, and then we did eventually move, we moved to Venice Beach, actually,
because my grandmother lived near.
And so my mother took us off the farm and we moved to Venice Beach.
And that was kind of a nice period.
It was the one time I saw my grandfather, one time.
I only saw him one time because my uncle came to town.
He called his father and he said, if you want to see me,
you have to see Ette also in the kids.
And so they came.
He came.
And that was the only time that I saw him.
But I also knew that I was missing my father so much, I decided to run away.
I was like five or four.
And I fill up a pillow with all of my necessities, and my mom said, okay,
and then I ran away.
I maybe made a block and a half.
I have no, I don't remember how it ended, but I didn't get very far.
So as I was growing up, eventually my father had a heart attack.
And so he came and lived with the family.
And he learned how to be a shoe repairman just by a print-tossing himself for free
with a shoe repair fellow who taught him the trade.
And we got a little shop.
And we all worked in that shop, all five of us.
And of course I was still kind of young.
So sometimes I would be in the back reading my books, you know.
And then sometimes I'd be on the cash register.
And eventually by the time I got to high school, I knew how to do some repair.
I could put the heels on, and I could sand them on the machines, and do a lot of that.
So we spent a lot of time there.
And where was the shoe shop?
Well, the first one, well, we had one on Dinker Street, but then we had one on 39th and Western, on Western.
And then the last one was a cross street from the City Hall.
And one day, I don't remember the year.
My father's name appeared in the Los Angeles Times because he was being called before Huac, House of Un-American Activities Committee.
And a few months later that shoe repair shop got shot into during the night.
And the other thing that happened is we had been going to this camp called Any Town.
And it was very nice camp.
It was organized by the National Conference of Christians and Jews in CCJ.
And my sister, it was very nice.
My sister was elected the mayor of Any Town.
And she was very proud of that.
And there was kids from all different high schools.
So it was a real mixture of people.
And the director of that program called her in, and she asked her, is that your dad?
My sister said, yes.
She said, you can't be the mayor of this organization anymore.
So that was devastating for my sister.
And my sister remembers everything as we were poor.
We didn't have stuff.
I had to, she had to run the shoe shop for a whole week once when my parents were ill.
And she, you know, she was like in the 11th grade or something.
And she held down the entire fort.
But she felt she suffered a lot behind that.
So also in these years, I started to demonstrate in the civil rights demonstrations.
But before we get to those demonstrations, like probably everybody you're interviewing, who's my age,
the first conversation that my father officially had with me about politics was when Emmett Till was murdered.
Because we saw the jet man.
He showed me, he says, birdie, that was my nickname.
You have to understand what this whole country is like.
And we had the jet magazine and the pictures and everything.
That's my first political conversation that I remember ever having.
Do you remember your reaction to seeing the pictures or to your father talking to him?
I was horrified.
He said, you know, things are not the way you may think they are.
And I want you to know this is something that has just happened.
I was just absolutely horrified.
I knew I felt different because I,
we moved around a lot.
And sometimes when I was quite young, I was in schools with all white kids.
And I felt somehow different.
I ended up making good friends with the other black girl and the third grade.
And she was also tall because that made it.
I was very tall for my age.
But I was not aware of that kind of violence.
And my father is another thing he had done.
He of course was very aware when he was 13 or 14,
a friend of his, a good friend of his brother was murdered by the police in custody.
Beat up and murdered.
And nobody wanted to do anything about this.
And my father collected money for the funeral, tried to get up church.
The churches were intimidated and would not allow the funeral to be at the church.
And they managed to do it.
I don't remember where.
And something he pointed out, he said, you know, the prostitutes were really good.
They really contributed a lot of money.
Because they understood what that kind of hardship was.
And that kind of brutality.
So that's when I started hearing some of those stories from my dad.
But that was the first conversation in it too.
Something else that affected our childhood a lot was my,
our parents' interracial marriage.
Because that was very unusual.
And people would stare at us and then we would smile back and stuff.
But we were very aware of that.
And my brother actually looks kind of like just a Jewish guy.
And he would get into fights with people saying, no, I'm Negro.
He would actually get into fist fights with them.
I don't know if these were black or white kids.
My father said that his mother always told them, your Negro, don't let anybody tell you that you're anything else.
And that's pretty much what my father told us as well.
Do you have a single memory of that?
That was just recurring theme.
And it's particularly interesting because I'm the darkest of the siblings.
So my sister could conceivably pass.
And my brother very easily would pass.
I mean, he would fight not to pass as white.
So that was very important.
And then I went to a lot of different schools.
But then I started going to Burrindo, Jr. High School and Burrindo, Jr. High.
And then to Los Angeles High.
And our neighborhood, we eventually moved to an area of Los Angeles,
which is like Adams and Vermont.
And it had been primarily African-American neighborhood.
But it rapidly changed into an immigrant neighborhood, mostly Central Americans.
So I learned Spanish.
So when I took Spanish in school, I talked to my neighbors and made friends with them.
And at LA High, I was in very, very mixed classes.
There were a lot of Jewish kids coming from, you know, like the Fairfax area.
There were a lot of Japanese kids, some of whom had been born in the internment camps.
And there were a lot of African-American kids.
And we got along pretty well.
I mean, there would be a fight in that school once every couple of months.
I don't like you see today.
But of course, we were very tracked.
And in Jr. High and part of high school, that's when I started to do dancing.
And it was through the dancing that I met some wonderful people who also were very involved in folk music.
And I just was kind of like a weirdo, you know, because I liked this old-time folk music and all of this stuff.
My brothers and sister, they were kind of like listening to Motown.
But I was doing my own thing.
And I eventually learned to play the guitar and the banjo.
And I liked different kinds of music.
And I'm so happy to realize that my, I had an uncle Earl, who was a fiddle learned, played old-time music way back.
In the early 1900s, he probably had a better ear than I had.
So what year did you graduate high school?
So I graduated, so I was involved in some of the demonstrations in Los Angeles at Woolworth and some of those kinds of things.
And I decided I wanted to go to Berkeley and I graduated in 1964.
So I arrived in Berkeley in the fall of 1964.
Can I back you up just a little bit then to your early high school and you and your family's reaction to what we talked about Emmett Till.
But back in 1955 in Montgomery or in, you know, 60 when the sit-in movement really starts to go throughout the South.
Were you tracking that in Los Angeles? Were you getting news?
You know, basically we were constantly looking at all of this happening on the news.
But that's the extent of it. You know, we were just very excited about it all and watching it on the news and seeing how all of this was progressing.
Okay. Okay, so sorry dinner. But so.
Right. So 64 Berkeley.
Because I had seen that there had been demonstrations at the Sheraton Palace to I think it was to integrate the staff there.
And all kinds of things had been happening at Berkeley.
So I figured that was the place to go. And I managed to get in.
They accepted me late because my grades weren't as good as there were supposed to be.
And but they got good enough because they saw my senior grades. And I went to Berkeley.
So when I had got accepted, all of all of the like dorms and the coops and all of that, they were full.
So my dad drove up with me and introduced me to different people that he knew from the movement in Berkeley.
And the first student at Berkeley to really befriend me and help me was Bettina Aptecker.
And she was like maybe she was a junior, maybe she was a sophomore. But she invited me to her house and she introduced me to a couple of people.
And her father of course is like a renowned communist scholar, member of the Communist Party back then, and did a lot of African American history work.
And I had heard of him and I kind of knew that you know these were established people.
But anyway, she was very friendly. She had me over for dinner and helped me plan my classes and who the TAs were and what I should do.
And that made all the difference in the world. I think if you were walking into that school and you didn't know anybody or you didn't have a group to associate with, you would really be lost.
And so Bettina got me started and I met a lot of very interesting people.
And did you just happen to meet her or was that through your father's connect?
No, somehow it wasn't just happened. No, it was through my father's connections. Although he didn't introduce me to her directly.
He introduced me to his friends which were people like Jessica Mittford and I don't know, Roscoe Proctor and a lot of activists from the Bay Area at that time.
Okay, so you really followed through your father's trust?
It was through my parents.
So I met people who were in the Du Bois Club and also in the Communist Party at that time at UC Berkeley.
So what happens at UC Berkeley in the fall of 1964 is the free speech movement.
And the free speech movement is largely because the students at Berkeley were mobilizing in support of the Civil Rights movement in Oakland and San Francisco at the time.
And some of the people I met actually had been freedom writers this summer previous.
And so when they tried to take down our tables and violate our right to free speech, we had a pretty massive movement and I got arrested in Sproul Hall.
And I was 17 at the time but I told him I was 18 so that I wouldn't go off all by myself to juvenile hall or something.
I just gave him a different year and my parents wouldn't have to come up to the Bay Area.
So I participated in that and that was very exciting moment.
Then the next major thing that happened at Berkeley as I decided I wanted to study abroad in Spain in 1966 and 1967.
Of course during this period we were demonstrating against the war in Vietnam.
We were demonstrating for civil rights. Very, very active. It was a very, very, very active period.
So I decided I wanted to study in Spain. I was a Spanish major by the way which was rather an odd thing to be but it was because of where I grew up.
Well through the eyes of 17 year old I was ready for all of this. In many ways this is why I went to Berkeley.
I was very excited about the demonstrations. I was always out there passing out leaflets as a member of the WWE Be Du Bois Club.
It was pretty early in the semester that the free speech movement started well.
It got started because it got started really quick. All it took was them to try to stop setting up the tables.
I don't know what they wanted to do that for because we really organized behind it.
And so of course Mario Savio was one of the key figures and we had rallies just about every day.
Bettina Abtecker also spoke. I spoke once as well and started to get my feet wet a little bit with giving speeches and things like that.
And it was mainly the free speech movement in 1966. Not in 1966, in 1964 of course.
That I remember. And exactly what happened between then and going to Spain I actually can't remember.
All of the things that we were involved in but constantly involved. Constantly doing things.
So when I interviewed to go to Spain they said well you got arrested in the free speech movement and you're going to a country that is a dictatorship.
And I said well my purpose is to go study. So I go. And I get to Spain and to Madrid and it truly was a repressive regime.
You saw there are so many different kinds of police and there were these police that you called the grises because they were gray.
And they would be standing on corners with some machine guns.
You didn't easily meet other political people.
We studied in what you call the facultad de letras, de filosofía.
Dendered the Berkeley folks, warn you at all, like be cool.
No they asked the question but I answered it to their satisfaction.
So I would find out there was a demonstration a day later because the way the Spanish students organized things as they would throw out leaflets, the demonstration would happen and it would be over.
Because it's not something that you you know you wait at the front of the campus and you pass out leaflets. That was not happening.
And mostly they were demonstrating against the Franco, the Franco regime and against the dictatorship.
And I did eventually meet some Spaniards who were progressive and involved in some of this and I said, well what should I do?
And they said well you should work with the American students because we work with the Spanish ones. So what do we do? We set up a table.
We get a table, we put it up in the facultad de filosofía, de letras.
And we took signatures of people who were opposed to the war in Vietnam because we figured we better not touch Franco Spain.
And I do believe that the purpose of collecting those signatures was to take them to the embassy and that was naive on our part.
But what was very interesting was with our little table there and I don't even remember how many days we were there, the press came.
Different people from the press and they say let us know if you ever get ready to do anything because they wanted to be present.
We say okay fine, well let you know.
So I was really mostly depressed most of the time that I was in Spain. I didn't find a boyfriend and I unfortunately didn't study flamenco guitar or whatever.
But eventually by the spring I had quite a few progressive friends, well they were considered revolutionary at that time.
And that was getting to be more and more fun.
So they were planning to have big demonstrations against the war in Vietnam on April 28th, 1967.
And they asked me if I would give a speech.
And I said I don't know, maybe I'll write a letter and you can read the letter.
So the director of our program was Carlos Blanco Aguinaga.
And he actually left Spain in the 30s as a child of Spaniards when the war was lost.
And he lived in refugee camps in southern Spain and he became a very prestigious professor in the University of California system.
And Spain didn't even want to accept him as the director of our study abroad program, but you see actually insisted that he be accepted.
So he actually, when he found out that I was some kind of an activist because I avoided all authority, I didn't go anywhere near him, he called me into his office like in October.
And he says, Roberta, Ronald Reagan is coming to town and you could go to the airport and he starts driving, driving me a diagram of the airport.
And he says and you can put sign up under your, you can put a sign under your coat.
And then when he gets there, you can open up your sign against the war in Vietnam and against Ronald Reagan.
I go, man, this guy's crazy. Fortunately Ronald Reagan didn't come because I think I might have gotten home sooner.
If he had actually come. But anyway, Carlos Blanco had a separate meeting with the American embassy because they didn't meet with him with the rest of the directors.
They met with him separately. And they basically told the directors of the programs, we can't protect your kids if they get involved in these demonstrations.
So you need to tell them to stay out of the demonstrations. So Blanco has this meeting with all of us and he tells us the same thing.
And then afterwards, I tell him, well, you know, they've asked me to give a speech. And he says, Roberta, I know you'll do the right thing.
He didn't tell me, don't give the speech.
So the day of this event, I go and they've taken over a whole building and they have a sign like from the fifth floor to the second floor, you know, Yankee's for the other Vietnam.
My juice is 1967 in Europe. People were burning little American flags and things like that.
So I go into the room where it's supposed to happen. The room is packed. The sound system doesn't work, but they say, don't worry, they'll get quiet.
There's a person before me. Nobody was listening to everybody. It was just chaos. And the reporters were asking me, what are they saying?
This is Spanish. You know, and the international reporters are asking me to translate for them.
So it's my turn to speak. I wish I had saved that speech. But as soon as I get up there, I get this standing ovation and then I make my points.
Oh, they got quiet, of course. And I get all of these, all of these plots and everything's just great. I'm so popular because I'm just like revolutionary student from the United States.
And then it's over. And like five students come up to me and they say, okay, now we have to run out the back way through this little forest and we have a taxi taking waiting for you.
And that taxi, what you want to do is go to the train station and go straight to Andalusia, Andalusia, so that you stay away for a couple of weeks.
So this whole thing will cool down. And then they'll forget about you. And I'm going, I am five feet ten inches. I am this color.
I had also gained a few pounds. I was so depressed. I was just eating at all hours. I know, okay, let me think about it.
And I go back to my apartment. I do take the taxi back to my little apartment. And I wasn't supposed to be living in a apartment. I was supposed to be living in a pence on because I broke all the rules.
And I found my friend who lived in a pence on a couple of blocks away. And she came over and she said, you know what, when, when I got back to my pence on, the woman who runs the pence on said that the police had been there looking for me.
And this woman was a Franco sympathizer, but she told them to come back. Oh, she'll be back in four hours knowing that she would probably be back sooner. So she alerted us that the police were looking for us.
So we said, oh, the police are looking for us. What are we going to do? And so we call Carlos Blanco Aguina and he says come to our house.
And so we pack up our suitcases and it's at an hour in Madrid where there aren't very many taxis. So we take this special kind of taxi and we have suitcases.
And my friend who was with me was blonde and then there's me. And there was a third person on the list who was Carol Wattenawe, a Japanese girl from Hawaii, because she had done a few things with us.
So we're in the cab going to the director's office and with our suitcases in the back and the guy is listening to the radio.
And he heard the announcement comes on.
And so he looks the Chica de Colores, particularly exotic for Spain at that time. It was very provincial. So he looks at his rear view mirror. He doesn't say anything, but he drops us off.
And so there we are at the director's house and we probably stayed there two or three days. It was very clear nobody's going to forget about us because they were making inquiries at the university.
There were different levels of sort of spies at the university repeatedly and the American Embassy as well was making inquiries. Where are they?
So we say, okay, let's just face the music. So we went back to our apartments. Well, she was in a pension. I was in a apartment.
So I get to my apartment and I'll leave out the story about eating my yogurt and walking past these people downstairs and all of that.
There was some guys and I just walked past them a couple of time and then eventually they come up and they say, not not.
Are you a bird Alexander playing clothes? I say yes. And they say, well, we're the playing clothes police and we're supposed to take you in. I say, okay.
And then we walk from my apartment to the Puerto del Sol. And we stop for coffee.
For my apartment to the Puerto del Sol, which was mostly downhill and it was a central jail. And at the Puerto del Sol at the jail there, you go downstairs. It's like a dungeon.
And I'm down there. I'm down there by myself because my friend hadn't gotten there yet. And somehow they had figured out the other prisoners because they had arrested a number of people because they were doing it before the May day.
Demonstration so they did it preemptively. So there were a lot of people in the jail and they figured out that I was from the United States. I tried to pretend like I didn't speak Spanish. That didn't go anywhere though.
And they started singing. We shall overcome.
So to make that long story a little bit shorter, I was deported. But I think it was more like I was kidnapped by the Spanish state under the orders of the American State Department because everybody we asked said, I said, why are you arresting me?
We don't know the American Embassy wants us to do it. They said that. They said that at every level. We don't know. We don't have anything to do with this.
And we were put on a train. There was row of police with their, my friend obviously eventually showed up with their machine guns. At every stop, at every stop, there would be Guar they are civil, the guy who wore the funny hats.
Right outside our car. I mean, we were 20. And they took us to Idle. We crossed the border to Undy and Carlos Blanco was there waiting for us. He had made that trip. He had driven up to give us money and to set us up.
So there's a little more to the story. We take the train to Paris and there were some immigrant workers like from Morocco. We're trying to tell them what happened to us and we're sharing food and there were some newspaper articles and we were trying to show them.
And we get to Paris and I say, okay, everybody, you hand me your hand me your bags because we don't have money to pay anybody to help us. And there's a whole bunch of people gathered around. The guy comes up and he says, are you Roberta Alexander, Carol Wattena, Ben, Carol Wynn? And he said, yes. And he says, I'm from CBS.
And we have a limousine to take you to the Hotel Jacques Sank, which is the fanciest hotel in Paris. But what we need you to do is give us an interview tomorrow morning at 5.30 so that we can have it in the state for the evening news.
And we said, okay, so then we take it off to the hotel Jacques Sank. It's a nice hotel. It was very, very, very, we were so fancy. We got to eat and all of that. And the one unfortunate thing is my parents somehow a radio station got through to me.
A Los Angeles radio station got through to me when I was under house arrest during this whole bit because they took us out of jail and put us in house arrest. And I gave them an interview and my parents heard it because I hadn't been able to get hold of my parents.
And then of course they see this on on well then I when I got to Paris I called them and then they see this interview on CBS and they were very proud. But there was reason to be afraid had it been Latin America it may not have turned out the same way.
So they gave us a very kind of like human interest interview a very friendly interview and we got to New York and we came back and we got back to went straight back to Berkeley.
How is the reception at Berkeley and the students following this?
Some people followed it. I was very disappointed in the people around the Du Bois Club and the Communist Party because they were not they were kind of like disinterested. I didn't see the I didn't see the fervor. It's about when I left.
I was subsequently I went around and talked to Abraham Lincoln brigade people. My uncle was in the Abraham Lincoln brigade actually.
And so I talked to them and so then I don't know if they invited me to go to a celebration of the fall of the Nazis in Germany.
And they wanted each delegation to have one older person in a youth. And so these Abraham brigade these does you know so would you like to be the youth.
So I went to this thing in East Germany and to speak it like something before you know three quarters of a million people.
But it was a very very very interesting trip because what they did is they fed us wonderful food. We had translators but there was no good political conversation.
It was just kind of dead. The only time I really had a good time was when I ran into some printers from Cuba. People who were studying printing in East Germany and they were from Cuba.
Well I could talk to them by myself for one and they were like full of you know this was 60, 67 and they were very enthusiastic and interested in talking about all of these ideas.
But I got an idea of kind of what the Soviet block was like and it wasn't looking too good to me.
And then I spoke in front of a crowd these Germans you know they they timed everything you know your talk can be 75 seconds but don't sit down until the interpreter finishes because they're simultaneous.
Yeah it's like Simon but it's not exactly so the German German takes much longer to say anything. And so the simultaneous interpreter would take a couple sentences longer when I finished I forgot and I sat down.
The Soviet youth was about 50 years old you know and it was just all not looking too good to me so it changed my attitude toward that whole deal.
So I came back to Berkeley.
Okay, 1967 back to Berkeley.
Okay 1967 back to Berkeley I completed oh I quit my associations with the Dubois Club and sort of the Communist Party group and I got involved with incredibly sectarian revolutionary quasi revolutionary intellectuals group for a little while.
That didn't last and I found out and then I got into another one of those groups and the other one of those groups which wasn't quite as as narrow they says well we don't take black people black people have to join the Black Panther Party.
That was the revolutionary union Bob Avaikian he was the leader and that was probably just as well was just a good thing. I had much better feelings at this point about the Black Panther Party than I had had previously because they started doing the community programs they started doing breakfast for school children and all of those kinds of programs.
And I liked the ten point platform I thought it was relevant still a relevant today.
What was your initial impression you said that it wasn't as positive at first?
Well I just thought at first and this is really colored by a sort of narrow view of what's correct I just was not impressed by I had heard Bobby speak Bobby Seal speak and I was thinking about today.
I think we want our share of the pie or something like that and I thought well I'm a socialist I want to divide up the pie between everybody but actually you know our piece of the pie maybe wasn't that wrong in retrospect I mean I just didn't respond to it.
So I started to be involved in the Black Panther Party by first going to the breakfast for school children program and it was at a church in Oakland and it was at the church.
It was at the church where there's a famous photo of Charles Bussey you know serving people's Charles Burcy I think serving people eggs and bacon and we worked really hard and that was a lot of fun doing that you know getting up and cooking the food and then we also would go around asking for donations of the food.
But the leadership of the party at that time they were pretty they were pretty sharp and they found out pretty quickly that I could spell I could type fast you know
and I was pretty well educated and so they assigned me to work on the Black Panther newspaper. So I was in the office I think it was shatic I think it was Berkeley was it's the but I was in the national office and it was technically Berkeley but I think it was considered the Oakland national office it was South Berkeley.
And so that's where I met big man because he was the editor of the newspaper and that's where I spent a lot of time. Now if you're a Black Panther it's not like I go to a meeting a couple times a week it was full time.
We pretty much gave our entire life we'd show up in the morning or people would have slept there all night and we get your assignments from the officer of the day who could have been a 17 year old you know deciding there was a woman named Martian 9.
I'm sure she was 17 when she was telling people okay you go here you go sell newspapers you do this you do that. So I did a little bit of everything I sold newspapers I did everything but basically I ended up working on the paper.
And so big man would pick the articles and I would type them into the adjuster writer which was this old machine that would line it up and I would correct the spelling and put in a few periods that kind of thing and then about not about once a week we would go to the printers which was in San Francisco and what was the was the tenderloin district.
And we would spend maybe 24 hours there laying out the paper you know because you have your copy and then you run it through this wax machine and then you could put it down and then you do your headlines and then Emory Douglas would show up who's the artist for the party I hope you're interviewing him.
You are now we are the artist for the party all of that art was Emory Douglas and he'd come in with different art things and he had a better eye of course for how to lay things out and and then we and then we go home exhausted and for some of that time I lived in North Richmond behind a church.
And for some of that time I lived in another area of North Richmond the reason I ended up in Richmond part of the reason was one of the problems that I had in the black Panther Party was being harassed by the guys.
It was just being harassed you know it was kind of the thing like we're all revolutionaries and everything belongs to everybody including you know you should be doing some you know revolutionary sexual favors for me I did not buy that.
And I got into a relationship with a nice guy but in some ways it protected me as well so you know I liked him but there was also some protection his name was Bobby Bowen and he was from the Richmond area so.
Can we talk a little bit more about the gender relationships and the party yeah we got a few hours everybody's story will be different depending on where you were.
Where you were and when you were there so I was there in 1969 Eldridge Cleaver was already gone and I had I wasn't impressed by his book so I'm nice somehow raping white women didn't seem like a revolutionary act to me although I could see that he was brilliant I had worked as an overseas operator for a while because I was working you know I worked in canaries and stuff because I was going to organize the industrial proletariat for a while.
I worked as an operator and he had he had those kind of phones that you have on a boat and he was rude to us and you knew it was Eldridge Cleaver because who else is going to have a black accent you know with this over and out phone and all of the leadership when I was there they were men and he was in jail too so the people who were the leaders were Bobby Seal.
David Hillyard, Masai, very important person, Hughitt Ray Hughitt and it was the three of them above all and Big Man was like the next tier but it was like this group and then there might be one or another coming in and they made the decision so they were smart they were very smart they had a lot of work to do.
They were very smart they had lots of interesting ideas they called the shots but there was like a class the vision they were up there drinking I don't know Shiva's regal and we were drinking bitter dog which was I'm sure you all know Tony Port and lemon juice and it actually tasted pretty good and it's probably gut rot but we were drinking it.
Now go get some of the Shiva's regal and we're drinking it. Tony Port and lemon juice. That was one item and they all hit on me one or another time but David Hillyard was very persistent and I had a real problem with him.
I was told to drive him home. Yeah, I was David. I was told to drive him home from something one night and he said well let's stop by your house I foolishly kind of did and I was supposed to be getting ribs ready for a picnic the next day.
One problem though is I didn't know how to do it forget my mom was white right moms with Jewish and my dad may have known how to do it but I didn't know so he makes his big deal makes fun to me whatever we get the ribs in oven because you get them cooked and then later you put them on the barbecue you don't cook them on a barbecue.
And then he starts looking and then he's just very very uncomfortable and he makes a lot of advances and I say no no no no no and he doesn't force it so I drive him back to his mother's house in West Oakland and I go to the park to the picnic the next morning and all these people come up and say where's the chairman.
Because everybody knew that he had gone home with me and I am inferring that everybody assumed that I had slept with him and he was coming back you know with me no I held I held the line on that I've subsequently been told that we saw we had agency with you Roberta of course I didn't know what they meant by agency but I mean this is far subsequently.
You can be my agency well you have some control over what you do so that kind of stuff really bothered me but it stopped once I got into a relationship.
Okay so okay then there's the big United Front Against Fascism in 19 it's in the summer of 1969 because I was in the party only in 1969.
They had figured out that I could give a pretty good speech I guess they had me doing political education classes and they asked me to speak at this event and it was in a big park and there were people came from all over the country I thought it might be a little premature to say it was the fascist country but it's okay.
So I gave a speech about women at this United Front Against Fascism and Eldridge had come out with women are other half not are lesser half but are other half so that all sounded very good but I talked some about a little bit better than what he had been saying earlier perhaps saying and doing.
So I use that and I think I talked about relationships evolving and yes there's problems but with the brothers because part of the issue was there was the women's liberation movement and then there was questions whether or not women should be in the black panthers or should they be in the women's liberation movement because clearly you know there were all of these issues in the black panthers and I I believe that that time that the right place to be was in the black panthers.
So I gave a speech after speech Angela Davis came up and introduced herself to me because she hadn't yet hit headlines and it was the strangest thing that she somebody just pitched the student at UCSD it was just like so strange but she told me Carlos Blanco Aguina got told her to introduce herself to me but after that
they decided at some point that big man and I would go to Japan together there was an invitation from the Zengap Korden and there were tickets so they decided to do this and I talked to my side and I said look my side I'm not going to talk straight nationalism because sometimes the panthers would be more nationalistic than other times.
Most of the documents are international very very international but that wasn't always how everybody saw things and he said fine so I'm sort of the tag team with big man you know and so sometimes I'd say how big man we have to do it this way or we have to do it that way.
So but before that happened we get to the airport in Tokyo and there's like some kind of cloak and daggers scene going on that we can't possibly understand but one group comes and they pick us up and they say hey we have to get out of here fast and we get on we get in some car and they're driving then this is big man's memory mostly so driving so fast and it's kind of scary.
But anyway we find out a few days later that these people are misinterpreting what we were saying and that they were the red army and I don't know if you remember but the red army did stuff like blow up railroad tracks and that kind of stuff in black powder party was not doing that kind of thing and so we had to disassociate ourselves from then and it's very hard you can't read anything in Japan and you can't read anything.
You can't hear any words that you might understand you know because it's a European language and so we got set up with a group that did films for the left and was called Ogawa Productions and they had relationships with everybody on the left and the left was very divided in Japan at the time.
The universities were occupied and then somebody be thrown off the fifth story or something like that but with these people we got around we also found out I don't know in my mind we realized but we should have known we only had one way tickets.
So we had to figure out a way to make some money so we tried to do we did that by charging for interviews.
So what did you understand as your mission? I mean what was the point of the trip?
You know that's a very good question. Our mission was that's very interesting. We saw our mission is to get out the story of the Black Panther Party and I think we also saw to learn about what's happening in Japan and come back and share it.
And there were a lot of things happening in Japan that we were very unaware of.
Were there others going to other countries? Were there the major trip?
Well this was an accident. See they somehow contacted the Black Panther Party National Headquarters and said we have a ticket and a lot of things I think happened like that.
1969 was a particularly chaotic year. The Panther Party had already grown so much. Something that I have not mentioned is that it was clearly infiltrated.
There was provocative tours going on. People will show up. Oh I just got out of prison. I want to join the party.
In Richmond this guy came up to me. I was driving in my injury. A little white rambler. You know these would leave a little square innocent looking cars.
And he says yeah I want to put some knives in the trunk of your car for now. And I said no.
And do you know the next morning on my way from North Richmond in this area that's completely abandoned before you can get on to the freeway going towards Berkeley and Oakland?
I hear a siren. I pull over. And within 30 seconds there were seven or eight cars there. Screeching in. You know like. And they searched everything.
And I don't think it was a coincidence that it happened the day after this guy wanted to put stuff.
I wanted to get in my trunk. Put whatever he wanted in my trunk. I think I was pretty lucky to get out of that one.
So they got an invitation to Japan. So we go to Japan. It happens to be that this journalist from Denmark comes and gets to know the black panthers and then they have a trip to Scandinavia.
And they're going to in the reunion. They're going to have a panel on foreign relations. Now there was other stuff that was much more official when they go to China.
They really met you know leaders in China and I guess in Algeria. They were recognized while you know while Eldridge was still part of the panthers before the split.
So yeah. So we just okay you're going to go to Japan now. It wasn't like okay we want you to do this and that.
And I think that there may be at one time they would have been that organized but not in 1969.
So what we did is we wanted to spread the message of what was happening with the black panther party.
We wanted to support the movements in Japan to the degree that we could figure out who's who.
And then we had to earn our keep our earn our tickets. And so we actually had some very interesting trips.
We met with little old women who probably half my age now who were sitting in and sleeping in on American airport strips, military base airport strips.
We met the second and third sons of farmers because the system for inheriting land was the first son inherits land.
Second and third then are pretty much a separate cast actually. And they would go to the cities and do construction work. People wouldn't marry them.
It was very much a cast like system. And we met with the Korean immigrants and workers in Japan and had no idea that there were all of these things going on.
The one place and this was thanks to these film these this film production company. They had relationships with all these people and they helped set it up.
We were followed the entire time except in my memory when we were with one particular interpreter.
I mean they were Japanese guys and they were out there waiting. We catch a cab and they would follow us.
And once the cab wanted to tell us he didn't know where it was and we thought he was being racist and we insisted because you would write down what it was.
And he was all up someplace and he stopped and asked and in the car behind stopped and asked you know where they're going and they just followed us.
Everything we did was public but whatever we just you know followed.
The one thing that everybody was united on at that time was to fight the construction of the new airport because it was on wonderful farming land.
And there were already enough air bases that that could have been accommodated with some of these US air bases.
And there would be there were demonstrations of hundreds of thousands of people.
And we spoke at that too. And it was really interesting because in their demonstrations you know the Japanese they lock arms and they tend to run.
But not everybody there's a role for everybody. So for the old folks they would collect night soil.
You know what night soil is? They would collect night soil and the cops would run they would have a net over them to try to protect themselves from rocks and stuff but it didn't protect them from the night soil.
And so they would be throwing this ship. It would go through. It was a real real problem and other people would be running.
And I can't remember but when your demonstration is over since you're running most of the time you feel pretty good.
You know I don't know how much was accomplished where they were massive demonstrations and we spoke there.
We also met with farmers, peasant farmers. And we saw a lot. We saw a lot of amazing things in Japan. When I got back.
So how long did you end up staying in Iraq?
You know I think we were there at least a month. Maybe five weeks. I have the notes someplace. Some notes just where we had gone.
And Big Man didn't come back with me. Big Man had to go to he went to Europe. He there was something he was supposed to do or tell.
I don't know. There was something he was supposed to do. He didn't come back to me with me.
I get back and then of course they have a separate customs just for me with a Japanese guy there.
And they asked for my telephone book and I said no you can't see my telephone book. And so whatever I got I got I got passed.
And so that was really the last big thing that I did in the party. I quit not too long after it.
Was it easy to get out?
I just walked away. Now but this is this is what happened. The whole time I look first of all there were levels of activities that I wasn't involved in in the Panthers.
The office was metal plated and there were sandbags in the office. So I kind of and I want to remember that I'm kind of oblivious to all of this.
And then there were other stuff. There was gun stuff going on and I was not part of it. They sent me to be trained to the shooting range or something.
I shot a 357 Magnum one time. I thought my arm was going to fall off and I shot an F16 does that sound right?
One time I thought my shoulder was going to fall off and it was noisy. I didn't want to have anything else to do with it and I did not.
So I'm sure some of the people you're going to be talking to know much more about all of that but I really in a naive way didn't.
But what I did notice is about once every two weeks there would be fire engines on each side of our block.
And one here and one there and that was kind of weird what's the fire engines there for.
And then a newspaper it was not the Berkeley bar but another one. I don't remember the name but I have it somewhere.
A Berkeley newspaper came found the Berkeley police plan for how they would vamp on the office.
And one of the things that I remember actually you could find that on the internet now. I think that's where I found it.
One of the things that I remember is that they would have the fire engines there because somehow they would blast their way into downstairs and then they would take these machine guns or whatever they are.
And they go like that. And then the upstairs would be on fire and I'd be up there typing that shit you know my little adjuster right here.
So I go wow you know I kind of saw you know this is this really is. I mean I had been writing Fred Hampton hadn't been killed yet but so many people had been arrested that year.
So many office had been vamped on. I don't know but reading this made it really come home. And so one I did not want to die for the Black Panther Party.
One, two I felt the party was infiltrated and a lot of times you know those infiltrators are the ones that bring you the guns and encourage or even carry out some of the crazier activities.
I never had in my mind a way to have a revolution that we could shoot our way into in this country that could be done through violence.
Even though I got a revolutionary terms and all that violence part of it I never you know can't even shoot a gun.
And third I was pregnant and I did not was not ready to take the responsibility of having a child.
And so for those three reasons I told them I'm going to go visit my parents but I didn't come back. Subsequently David Hilliard figured out where who had my all my books because I had this huge library you know Mao and then all the revolution marks and stuff.
And he came in intimidated those folks and took all my books.
So the one thing is I think this was a period in the party where there was like a purge kind of thing going on so somebody would leave and they call them a running dog lackey several other words they never published anything like that about me.
I sent them everything I had from the Japan trip and I was sorry that I did that but somehow subsequently a lot of that's been recovered because we had a woman who was doing research on that project for us and she she found out a lot of that information.
So then I was back in the United States and with my parents.
I lived there for a year and I talked to Carlos Blanco because I was at doing a typing job at that point and he says come down to San Diego because we are starting third college.
Can we stop for a minute?
Sure. Bring it back to where we stopped which was third college in San Diego.
Okay so I gave you the wrong name it was in Lumumba Sapata College.
Okay so what had happened in fall of 68 and 69 is students at that college including Angela Davis and African American students and the Chicano students they got together and they said we want a college that
that will teach us our history as well as white students were involved in it as well.
And these are students who are originally at San Diego State?
They were already at UCSD because the way they were developing UCSD was to have colleges so that the university wouldn't feel so inhumane or you know there'd be an intimate touch.
And they actually and this is when there was a lot of organizing going around all over for ethnic studies departments and all of that and I went to a lot of those demonstrations I do remember those.
And they were granted Lumumba Sapata College but that was that temporary name.
So the university called it third college so when I called Carlos Blanco he says come down we can get you a job at third college.
So what am I 23?
They have me interview for the resident dean position.
And the people on the interviewing committee are students and a couple of other people.
And they give me the job of resident dean of third college the first year of its existence.
Start at the top.
Yeah so okay so to be resident dean one of the perks is you have this house.
And around the house which is you know like a 70s flat house.
And all around the house are the big dorms.
And they've been doing recruiting of students to come to third college at all levels but especially the freshman level and recruiting faculty and staff administrators.
Okay so far so good.
But from the very beginning this effort was infiltrated.
So that there were a couple of administrators who the university insisted be hired even though the committee, the so-called you know committee led by students faculty and staff didn't want that person to be.
They insisted some of these people be hired.
And this individual stood up at the very first meeting and started talking about the black people don't have the same you know this is not serving black people.
This is just serving you whites and chicanos.
And so it was very divisive from the very beginning.
And here I am in this fish bowl with the students around and amongst the student body the same thing had already happened.
In fact there were guys kind of very similar to some of them who showed up in the black Panther party.
The prison you know the kind of they stare at you and they never take their eye away because that's how they've learned to behave you know and to intimidate and to be the alpha individual.
There were there were those.
And I very early on was attacked because look at my background.
You know I grew up in Latino area. I've been in the black Panther party. I've been to Spain. I danced with my progressive friends.
I even sing folk music you know and I was attacked for having relationships with everybody.
I was even told at a BSU meeting black student meeting Robert as far as we know you like chicanos but you like black people.
You know was that kind of thing. It was extremely divisive.
And we had courses like third world studies. We had some fabulous professors.
And I don't think there was a university in this country that had to the degree that we had at that amount of control had that potential to be something fabulous.
But I'm quite sure it was probably part of the Coentel program just like the Panthers that suffered from the Coentel program.
There was no doubt about it and it turned into like I have a tendency when things are really bad to forget.
But I was threatened one night at gunpoint and I left and I went to Carlos Blanco's house.
He just keeps coming up and they go, Roberta don't you remember this is what they said they said they're going to get you and stuff and that's why you.
It was a very difficult time.
So I quit after nine months because among other things I was not a good resident dean.
I was supposed to be putting on dances and things and I was supposed to say oh you broke a window.
Okay your family is going to have to pay for it and all that kind of stuff.
And I was awful. It was absolutely awful. It was the wrong job. I didn't like it.
I actually probably quit before I was going to get fired.
So I quit and I applied to two places for graduate school.
I applied to the School of Education at Harvard because they had sent me some advertisement when I was a senior at Berkeley.
And I applied to the Literature Department at UCSD.
Well Harvard offered me a full scholarship to be in their master's program and I figured that wasn't going to make it because it was cold back there.
And I was a little insulted. And so I did the program at UCSD.
I got a PhD in comparative literature.
Let me ask you one quick question. It's going back for just a second.
Did you, because you were talking about folks challenging you sort of on the variety of your interests and your background while at the third college.
Did this come up in the Black Panther Party as well at all?
You know not so much but it came up around food.
So you heard my story about the ribs.
So in the, no, there were a lot of light skin.
There were a number of light skinned people.
There is antagonism based on skin color in the Black community.
And people who are lighter skinned are seen as more privileged and some people find it more attractive or all that kind of stuff.
And there's a long history of that in this country.
That didn't make itself apparent to me while I was in the Black Panther Party.
But having been raised by a Jewish mom who wasn't even that good a cook, we once in a while had to cook for everybody.
So me and this other girl and her name was, I want to say shelly. Her name was Shelly.
And she was very light skinned and her, and clearly her mom was white too, it was one of those things.
And we had to cook.
So I had a specialty which was tuna casserole that comes out of the joy of cooking book with Kellogg's, not frosted, but flakes that you put on top to give it that little crunch and probably cream a mushroom soup.
No. That did not go over me and Shelly where the only people eating that thing.
Nobody touched it. We heard about it. We heard about it later.
I did my best.
What's this man is?
But you know another contradiction for me I'll be honest. You know, it's very often there were so many times when African American men would be with white women, especially in the educated zone, you know, that I would kind of like.
And yeah, but that's kind of hard because my mom's white.
So there is that it's a very, very, very complicated dynamic.
And working on the project that I've been working on recently I hear a little bit about it sometimes. It's not hostile, but you know, that's a dynamic and it's out there.
Status based on skin color.
Well, thank you for answering that. So back to, so starting your graduate program.
Right. So that was just a lot of fun. You know, it was a graduate program. At that time there were there were grants.
I got a Ford grant, which you know, if you read Naomi Klein, you know, was a lot dirtier than I may have thought of, but they didn't influence what I was doing.
And I got a PhD in comparative literature, but I probably was in the wrong area because my my dissertation was the fictional portrayal of popular movements.
So I read these different books, you know, about Haiti and Cuba and Mexico and the United States about slave rebellions and revolutions.
And that's whatever it was about. But then after I got that degree, I only played to one college and I recognized that I didn't want to be in the academy.
You know, I didn't want to have that publish or perish and the kind of competition that I saw within faculty members and, you know, the that whole process.
And so I actually started teaching adult school for a while. And I taught adult school mostly ESL for and a lot of refugees from Vietnam for about 12 years.
And that was interesting too to hear their stories because that forced me to see things in a little more complex way.
And then fortunately I was recruited to organize the ESL program at city college. And that's where I was for the last 25 years.
And I feel like at city college, my contribution was primarily becoming the department chair. And I was there at the time for the English department.
And I was there at a time when I could really turn around the composition of the faculty so that we have increasingly diverse faculty, a progressive faculty and a very dedicated faculty and the department functions well.
And that's quite a good legacy because there's a lot of non-functioning dysfunctional English departments out there in every other kind of department.
So that was good. But also at city college, I also was responsible for about four or five years for the labor studies program.
It was a program that was floundering for a while. It's always a difficult program to make successful in San Diego.
And so we offered an AA, an associate's degree in labor studies. And so it would be a class in the history of labor.
And now there is a class I wasn't involved with that in organizing. And then there's lots of classes like workers, compensation and disability and a lot of things about law, you know, and how to be as well as leadership classes.
And I introduced the occupational safety and health classes. And those are very important. And we got a bigger variety of people to come to those classes.
And we worked with people from the UCLA labor program to organize those. And people from up there came down to teach a number of those classes.
One of the reasons I think it's difficult is because I'm not sure the leadership of all the unions really want to develop the next generation to take their place.
That's one. Now that would be different for different locals and different leaders.
Another one is as many of them have their built-in classes that they give for shop stewards or whatever. So there's some, you know, overlap or redundancy.
Yeah, so that is one of the one of the struggles I used to go to the meetings of the Central Labor Council regularly. And they would say this is good. This is good. This is good. This is good. But then they didn't send the people to the classes. So it's always a struggle to keep your classes.
Class is full. Now there is a labor studies program in Los Angeles. L.A. Trade Tech, I believe, which is very successful. And you know, we're trying to follow some of his examples. But it hasn't taken off. So anytime there's a fallen enrollment, we have a fall there. However, they are doing some very interesting things. Now they're developing internships for people. And they're working with CPI.
Is it Stanford?
Center for Policy Initiative.
Yeah. It's local Center for Policy and Initiative. And so they're getting a lot of really good hands-on experience and they're getting paid for doing it as well.
So there is pretty good cohort of people who are going through that. So those, you know, that covers 25 years of my life. But there was a lot of work. And I felt it was I was able to do productive, really good things there.
I also taught in the Chicano Studies program. Yeah, and there was a little bit of, you know, there was a little bit of conflict. But yeah, you know, some people wanted to keep me out. But she had no reason that the administrator to do so.
I says, if you don't want me to do it because I'm not Chicano, just say that and I won't do it. You know, because, you know, but that wasn't it. She, oops, did I miss something up?
Yeah, you know, it didn't turn out to be a problem. Actually, that was one of my favorite places. Black studies I would have liked to have taught, but it just didn't work out. Just didn't work out because that was the big English person.
Did third college survive? Yes. Innocence. It's now called Third Good Marshall. And I think most of the curriculum, you know, there's some still there are still some elements from third college.
But it certainly is not the revolution experiment. The revolutionary experiment that it started out to be. Not the limo sabata.
It's not the limo sabata. I don't know that it's serving Latino, African-American and poor folks population in the same sense. Yeah. I mean, look at the, you know, when I went to Berkeley, there was not even 1% African-American, right?
I think we're getting close to that too. And on the UCSD campuses, I mean, it's very, very low.
So it's fall, it was up and falling as falling. Was it up higher? Yeah, for a while it was up higher. Well, with third college and with affirmative action, but that has fallen to as low as it was in 1964 on some of these campuses.
I have a lot of Asian, but yeah, they do not have that kind of representation. They do have quite a lot more Latino and Chicano. But see, college is very mixed.
It's still much more heavily Latino now because that's what's happening with the demographic.
But yeah, no, we've gone back. We've gone back. I mean, to think that the packing houses are in many respects, just as bad as they were when my father was working there in 1932 or something.
And not in unions. To look at the police brutality that we have now and the murders, just as well. I don't have, my tongue was happening in the South, but in Oakland, California.
It's similar to where we are now.
Not very true. But there is some good stuff. All right, there's some good stuff that I think is very important. And I don't think it's just unique to San Diego, but it is a little bit unique to San Diego.
There is a community organization called Pillars of the Community, and I'm now relatively active in at least one aspect of that organization.
It's a faith-based organization, but you're Muslim. See, my family, we got the Black, we got to Jewish, and pretty much the only thing that was left that people would be mad at would be the Muslim.
So my son decided to fix that, and he converted to Islam a long time ago, 20 years ago.
So now I got the Muslim thing, and so I got grandson's, whose mother's from Gujarat, Gujarat is an interesting place to be Muslim. So I got Urdu speaking grandson's, who wear their kufi, and then I've been to weddings with the Yamaha.
We got it all covered. What's left?
Oh, God, yeah, that's right. In the Native American stuff. Yeah. So our family kind of just happened that way.
So it's a faith-based organization, but there's a lot of people who are not Muslim, who are served by the organization and also work with in it.
They have a storefront in Encanto in Southeast San Diego, which is not unlike the Black Panther storefronts that we used to have except this one doesn't have two stories.
And there's a lot of community activities that take place. Just be probably more prepared to go through all of them.
One of the, one of the infacies is helping people who get out of prison, adjust and succeed in life outside of prison.
Other things that they're doing is they're organizing within the community to get people more politically active.
A major thrust of campaign now is the San Diego 33 campaign. And that's because in the whole state of California, I'm not sure the whole state of California is aware of this.
There's a penal code, penal code, 182.5. And that penal code is the gang documentation. And it's based on one of these California initiatives that got passed in the early 2000s.
And it says, if you have, if they can demonstrate that you've done two or three things, then they can say you are a gang member.
So those two or three things can be, if you happen to be wearing the color green, if you happen to be standing in your neighborhood in front of your grandmother's house, which somebody decided is a gang house.
If you happen to be taken to a gang member, which could be your neighbor, right? That's enough. And God forbid you do rap and put it on the internet, right? That's enough.
You're a, you're a documented gang member, but you don't know that. And the documented gang members are from the ages of eight, ages of nine up.
And there's thousands of them in the state of California. And so the district attorney in San Diego got it in her head that she's going to test this out.
So she arrests 33 African American men about two years ago, including Aaron Harvey and Brandon, Brandon Duncan.
Aaron Harvey at the time was in Las Vegas, getting ready to study real estate and become a rich guy, so in his real estate.
And he hears all these helicopters and shit and they, and they land in the machine guns and sweat and he goes out and he says, you guys making too much noise. You must lost your guy by now.
Whoever you're looking for is long gone. And then it turned out they were looking for him. And what am I charged with? And there's this whole series of violent and events in San Diego. You're charged with all this.
He says, I wasn't even in San Diego. We know you weren't in San Diego, but you're a documented gang member and a gang carried it out. And we're going to put you in jail and we're charging you with all of these things.
Did it include murder? No, not cases shooting shootings.
And jail for seven months, they know perfectly well he had nothing to do with it and didn't have and didn't even know about it. And he says, well, what do I get out of it?
Why me? He says, because your reputation went up with these, you know, with this violence or whatever your street cred or whatever. And he's not even living in San Diego.
So I don't know why they wanted to mess with him because his family came together and they joined forces with the pillars of the community and reclaiming the community and another project, which is broader than pillars in San Diego and did not just let him be stuck in jail.
Because what most people do, they do not have legal resources and they make plea bargain because they're facing 50 years in prison. And they say, well, you just say guilty and will give you eight or whatever.
So they admit to something that they did not do.
People admit actually admit to because they're terrified.
So one young man with 19 or so he signed a case of an anti-cancelor case. He was actually on Facebook, but he signed his own idea to be serving the country.
And he didn't know how to connect. So between the family community and their own good sense, they didn't sign a deal and they spent seven months in jail.
Being shackled, being handcuffed, going back and forth to jury cases and so forth, and finally being free.
But as a consequence of that, there is a pretty decent movement in San Diego now addressing these police activities.
So pillars of the community is involved in that. They also do things like workshops, what are your rights if you get stopped? What can you do? What should you not do? What you don't have to do?
And all of that and what the consequences are.
And two years ago, when I was a two years ago, my son, the Muslim, came up with the idea to do a rap CD because he's of the brand that doesn't even listen to music, little rap.
And they have connections with so many relationships with so many community folks that they got a major rapper from San Diego to put together a rap album that was a meaningful rap album to speak to the people in the streets who like listening to rap.
Now when I put it on, it's still rap and it's kind of hard to listen to, but it's a community activity.
So then where I'm involved is, wasn't the rap album or the sound technician or anything, but another program we started last summer was just getting people together to write their story, any aspect of their own story that they want to do, but make it a story, not your whole long life.
And then the goal of doing that would be we would invite your family and some friends, small gathering, we weren't looking at 500 people, didn't want that.
And friends, and you would read it to them. And we've done that three different times with three different groups.
And it is an amazing process to go through, absolutely amazing, because these people, we didn't ask them to, but they all found, sometimes they're most traumatic incident in their life.
And sometimes they're most, a moment of achievement and then awareness of where they had been.
And so coincidentally, not exactly on purpose, it's all people of color, more or less, I mean it's all African American, it's Chicano, and we work together, everybody work together.
And you have to trust, because you're trying to write, you read it to somebody else, and somebody else tells you what they think, and maybe you can make this a letter, it'll work.
And so there are all kinds of stories, some of them are neglect, some of them are seeing your mother murdered in front of you.
What one of them is that, some is being bussed to another school system, and what that does to your morale, you know, if you get bussed to like a white school, education things, one was an incredible education achievement, the guy had background prison and breaking the law and all kinds of stuff.
Aaron Harvey, one of the important people who, important in that, he's gone so public and brought the issue public for the San Diego 33, wrote a story about visiting his uncle in jail, and then he's gone with his mother, and then the second part of the story, it's him who's in jail.
And pretty much the same scenario. People with some serious prison experiences, I mean, I learned, I had to say, you know, I don't know what it's like, you know, to live in a family where your parents are drug addicts, and what did that look like? What was it like when you guys came home?
You know, so I learned so much, and at the same time, these are people who are thriving and struggling to thrive. I mean, they're struggling with life now. It's not easy. Coincidentally, at least half of them are related to to city college and one way or another.
I have a Palestinian colleague who was actually helped start that program, and she just gave a story about how, well, if you, people say, where are you from? She said, I'm from Detroit. No, where are you really from?
You know, and then how she's gotten stereotyped and sort of branded and how that's an issue for folks and how to identify yourself and what the reactions are. So it's a wide variety. So, okay, so these people read their stories, and that was very successful.
And then we thought in the opportunity, because here we have a press called City Works Press, and it's an independent press, and now those stories are going to get published.
Yeah. And Erica, I'm not sure if she's going to get it in on time, because we have to get it. They said she would write a blurb. Big man wrote a wonderful blurb about it and how important it is to get these stories out.
And I don't know if you know Jimmy Santiago Blackout or Luis Rodriguez. Both of them, they are very important Chicano writers, and one of them had experience with gangs, the other one, a lot of experience with prisons and stuff, and that's what they wrote about.
And we teach them a lot in our classes. And so it's really an exciting project. We're going to pick it up again and see where it goes. So it's modest, but altogether we included everybody who wanted to be included in the publishing part. We included everybody, 19 authors.
So there's one very explicit connection there, talking about the blurbs with the Black Panther Party, but can you tell me about, have there been other opportunities for sort of bringing in lessons of your own experience, the Black Panther Party to the work that's going on in San Diego now?
You know, I've gone to classes, pretty much. I've gone to classes. And then last year, and I've talked to classes and given presentations, I'm being asked to be involved in a panel at San Diego State. I've spoken twice at UCSD.
And it was usually at times when there was organization going on. Once shortly after there were some awful incidents in UCSD, I don't know if you're familiar with them, but there was like, I don't know, effigies of like, no, not effigy, cook, clucks, but very threatening kinds of stuff. Do you remember what it?
Yeah, they had this so-called comp through. Nooses on the campus. Yeah. And then graffiti, you know, anti-Black graffiti. So I've spoken at UCSD a few times, and I have those things coming up when Big Man came down, I presented him and spoke to those. And yeah, that's pretty much the extent.
I'm not a star. I, you know, I just happen to be in a lot of places. No, I'm not a star. I just, been in some places. I've done things my life where I didn't know what the risks were. Always. Yeah, I was in the Panthers for a year, serious year.
And I met some people who I respect very, very much, but I did not establish the ongoing relationships, particularly with women.
Part of the problem with the Panthers, one of the problems, we didn't take care of ourselves, you even hear this from America Huggins. We did not take care of ourselves. We were just running all the time. And some of that included personal relations.
And I'm talking only about my year, 1969 in Oakland headquarters. I cannot speak for what was going on in every place else. And later.
So how did that manifest when you said not taking care of yourselves?
Well, part of what I was thinking about is not taking care of ourselves is for me anyway, having good relationships with other women in the party.
There just wasn't any time. You're just running around all the time. Or you go home and sleep. If you had your own home or you'd sleep there, we were always doing something.
So, for example, I don't think I spoke to anybody else about the sexual harassment. Now, that seems a little silly. You know, that's, that it shouldn't have been that way.
So, I think that the stress or mental health repercussions of being in the high stress life situation.
You know, I never thought about it. I think my way to deal with high stress is to forget. Like the details, I think my highest stress was actually third college, believe it or not.
And I've forgotten the details. I've forgotten. I can just tell you, you know, Carlos Blanco and his entire family tells me that I was threatened by guns. I would not have said.
I would say somebody was intimidating me and I left, but I didn't remember the guns and everybody else did.
So, it's kind of like, yeah, there's an emotional toll. But I think I just sort of suppressed that emotional toll and keep on keeping on.
There's an emotional toll also. You know, I always said, oh, well, those people who say, I had a teacher in high school. And he said, it was like some stupid class, like, I don't know, social adjustment or something.
And this was a light skinned black guy. He wore some kind of two-pain and looked like shoe polished us on the back of his head. And one day he said, the kids who are worst adjusted are the ones who are born out of wedlock.
Well, for sure, I was born out of wedlock because it was illegal to be married and mixed race. And I said, oh, he's crazy because I have the advantage of being both and the born out of wedlock, well, that never gave me trouble.
But being mixed race in a time of identity politics is a problem. And I have to be really honest. I got a lot of Jewish in me. I was very close to my grandmother.
You know, I walk through the world as African-American. I'm fine with that. My grandmother even would ask me, I said, I got a boyfriend. She would say, is he Jewish?
You know, it's just there. So when we're talking about Israel and Palestine, yes, my grandmother was very upset with Israeli policies regarding Palestine. Very upset.
And she would be in arguments with all her Jewish old lady friends all the time about that. But then I don't want to hear anything that sounds a little bit like anti-Semitic.
You know, even though I might even be getting kidded by my Muslim grandkids or whatever. No, what do you tell me? You got to understand the history of the Jews.
And yes, what there, what large aspects of the government is doing now is really bad. But don't forget, there's people in Israel who don't agree. And they have to be pretty brave if they're fighting against this mainstream. So this is what, so I'm always navigating that.
I do not like to go to anything that's strictly racial based. I don't go to the African-American faculty staff meetings. So kind of over that. And I don't go to the 100% Chicano things. And I'm always invited. I'm always invited to those things.
And it's probably stupid of me not to go. But I don't want to go to anything that's so racially, that's so racially based. That's just, you know, I think that's not the pan. Well, part of it, you know, the Panthers was interesting about the Panthers is they did reach out to other groups.
It wasn't, yes, we want to be a black group. But we want to reach out to other groups, not, you know, attack them and fight over the crumbs. And I think that's very, that that's, that's very important. And they did do that. And once in a while nationalism would come in. But there's reasons for black people to have a chip on their shoulder.
You know, it's have to discuss why that's there. If we, if chip on the shoulder is the right expression, it's not.
Wonderful. Well, I think I got most of it.
I think we could talk for hours more and would love to do that. But we should probably start to wrap up. Is there something that, is there anything that you thought I was going to ask that I didn't ask?
They should have asked today in the conversation.
I'll think of that tonight.
We covered a lot of territory.
I would just like to add that my sister also is pretty much dedicated her life to health care, African American community, and has organized a lot of things.
My brother, because she became a medical doctor, and neither of our parents had gone to college. My brother became, he, he actually suffered the most in the McCarthy period.
The FBI even came and visited him in San Luis Obispo when he was in college and everything. So he kind of stayed away from that activist kind of thing, but he came the CEO of, no, no.
The chief medical officer of Kaiser, of a whole section of Kaiser and Los Angeles. And I think he actually changed the culture of the hospital.
At least that's how people talked. And they, they, they, and they talk to us.
When Dr. Alex, because he, he had relationship with the staff, with the custodians, with the nurses, and the doctors, and okay, you know.
But they says, when Dr. Alexander first came, we, we used to talk amongst ourselves and we say, is he a brother? Or what?
And then they figured it out, you know, that yes, yes, yes, he was. And, you know, in his heart above all, you know, and in his allegiances, and who he thought wasn't, you know, was important.
Yeah. And that's the legacy of the family. And my other regret is that I didn't, I interviewed my aunt, I interviewed my brother, I interviewed my sister. This is after my father's death.
And after my mother's death, and I interviewed some cousins, but I never interviewed my mother. And that was a big mistake.
Because I think she was the solid rock behind that whole operation, holding that family together, going to a holiness church in Paris, California. She had to go too.
You know, you know, with my uncle and aunt, and how did she do it?
I like, yeah. Yeah. You can carry, you carried her with you though.
Yeah. It's that quiet part, that, that, that's quite strange that she had. Yeah.
Well, thank you so much. Thank you for everything you've done. And obviously, but also for spending time with us today, and telling this incredibly important story.
Thank you. Yeah. Thank you. And I want to pick your brains about what to do with my, all my stuff.
Okay. Yes. I got more.
This has been a presentation of the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.